this is kind of crazy to me because uh
well let me just say who's sitting here
sitting together for the first time and
I don't know how many years
hold hands guys oh must be killing oh my
god Euler anybody wants a disinfectant
sitting here are the two founding
members the guys who started all Chris
and rich Robinson who started the Black
Crowes many many years ago you are in
the same room and you're here today to
announce what Chris we're announcing
that the Black Crowes are together and
that we're going on to her next next
summer we're playing the Bowery Ballroom
tonight how did this Wow this is a
miracle I don't care what you tell me
this is a he's saying it like he doesn't
believe rich first of all this is a
miracle how does this happen that you
and Chris you guys I love your band I
love the black rose and and rich isn't
it something of a miracle when two guys
born into a family actually can write
and perform music together I mean to me
it's a billion to one shot am i right or
am I wrong I think you're right yeah you
know I think ultimately we share a
similar experience
you know from two different perspectives
obviously it's an amazing story to me
because there are very few brothers and
the way I look at you two guys you
filled in each other's kind of missing
parts rich you can play the guitar Chris
you had no interest in playing guitar
but Chris was the singer Chris could
come up with lyrics and you could come
up with these fabulous riffs and this
music what are the [ __ ] odds of you
know which one thing that Keith Richards
found Mick Jagger but they weren't born
into the same family at the same shop
it's legendary that the Robinson
brothers as great as you guys are
together you could never really be in
the same room Chris I had you on two
years ago no no I said he said some
shitty things it's a horrible thing you
said some bad thing I was in a negative
place but you know you know what I've
apologized to rich about that how did
this come about that your two guys even
started talking
you hadn't talked in what four years you
said I know things here six years I no
longer have her brother he doesn't exist
you can't stand each other you don't
want to be in a room together and here
you are sitting in my studio I just
found my you know and I mean a lot of
things have changed for me in the last
two years you know I was in a
relationship that was failing I was in a
negative place you make some big changes
in your life I mean I found I mean I
have an amazing partner amazing you have
a new girlfriend new girlfriend
everything good there it's been going on
for a couple of years it's incredible
right I mean a big part of like helping
me like you know leave behind some
negative things and like look at oh well
you know depression and those kind of
things were you clinically depressed did
you have to go to a psychiatrist and say
hey I think I'm sorry I have a therapist
that I've been working with for a long
time was there an epiphany in therapy
where you said you know what I miss my
brother what always happens is
communication I don't know you know what
I mean I can only guess rich is doing it
you know and only thing he's hearing for
me is like my negative books
Chris hasn't changed but you know it's
funny like that what you said is you
know change you know and to be I just
think both of our trajectories since
we've haven't been in a band together
you know I'm so busy with the CRB and
trying to make this happen and writing
the songs and really enjoying myself and
I needed to go into the wilderness I
needed to deconstruct the that first
part of my life and and the the good the
bad the indifferent all of it right I
mean I think that's a true part of the
artist at least in my artistic waking
life well when he's having the same
thing you know but we're just don't
we're you know rich has has his band and
I think being rich rich did you miss
your brother or had you been fed up with
the fighting and all the nonsense
I was definitely fed up with the
fighting you know and it's it was it was
unhealthy who has this idea that we
could actually get along and be in a
band together again we have a we have a
friend that that we that is in between
us and does it well it's name is Greg I
thought it was doctor
all right who picked up the phone and
called what we both did
right interestingly at different times
like right but right around the same
time and and and you know look I was
going out playing you know songs you
know in my new band and playing crow
songs cuz a lot of the guys from the
crows are in my band and and no matter
what it is there's that half of me that
was missing right and and so in that
same sense although it was great to play
with those guys and those guys are
brilliant and it was cool and fun but
there's it's almost like the more I
delved into that the more it was obvious
there was a glaring omission which was
my brother